rock human females are visually
indistinguishable from human women the
only real way to tell them apart is to
check if they are subscribed to the new
world review which grants any type of
human rock or regular frequent jojo
content uploaded straight into their
youtube feed which to be perfectly frank
you should all want whether you are a
rock or not
a rock so actually i don't know maybe
that's not the best tell after all
hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we have
madness utter utter madness to present
with chapter 99 of joe jolion because
just
what the hell happened still not
entirely solid on
all of that but it was hype it was
certainly hype and this was probably by
far the most enjoyable chapter of joe
jolion that i have had the pleasure of
reading and i knew we were in for
something pretty special
this time around when we began with the
very simple words
rock humans what they are is and then
proceeded to have a bit of a biology
class but this was very exciting because
araki only really tends to dump masses
and masses of information like this
when we are certainly approaching the
end game of a part in fact the whole
thing really gave me some nostalgic part
two vibes where all of a sudden we were
given the background of cars and the
pillarmen right before launching into
our final conflict
i think this is definitely a bit
different because while we now know how
rock humans came to exist and i suppose
exactly what they are right down to
their biological composition this
chapter still
in true jojo leon's style doesn't answer
anywhere near as many questions
as it asks but the first piece of
insanity i want to go through is the
opening page which presents us with a
collage of history's most famous women
and the claim that in this universe they
were all rock humans
actually that's not necessarily accurate
it basically says that rock human women
are indistinguishable from human women
so i suppose it's possible that not all
of the figures here are rock humans
perhaps even none of them are rock
humans and instead this is being used to
tell us hey
you can't tell which of these women is a
rock human or not which becomes
quite interesting in regards to some
specific characters
and so what i do see are some very
familiar faces such as cleopatra joan of
arc queen elizabeth the first etc but
there are some even more familiar faces
amongst them such as enya but much more
surprisingly and something i didn't
notice the first time around we also
have hermes from part 6 which was
unexpected to say the least but at the
same time it makes perfect sense really
i mean it's tricky to keep a handle on
because part 8 is more strongly
borrowing from part 4 but georgiolion
does take place in 2011 which is the
exact same year that stone ocean took
place in the original universe so it
only stands to reason that there is an
alternate hermes out there in existence
which is very exciting because it's
making the alternate universe feel a lot
more
um complete i guess whereas before
everything felt very part 1-4 centric
which also made sense i guess because
that could have led into a part nine
which more closely resembled five and
six but i don't know about that anymore
because things are feeling like i said
like they're starting to complete here
like we're coming full circle
in this entire jojo business and not
just because of the reference of a
single character but because the journey
that we went on during this chapter was
essentially won through
jojo history alternate universe jojo
history but still
there is a ton of reference in this
chapter many of them confusing my poor
brain thing but
still they're there what i do want to
ask before moving on is who
is the bikini woman if it's a reference
to a famous woman or image then i'm more
than happy to admit that i am uncultured
spine
and just don't know but she looks very
familiar and more strikingly like an
in-universe character
plus she gets by far the biggest panel
and is thus the focal point
and the only thing that really comes to
mind is is this josephumi's mother you
know the one that basically left him for
dead on the beach because that tragic
story goes on to work quite nicely with
what we're told about how rock human
mothers
rarely have any kind of affection for
their children or even a parental
relationship so this whole josephumi
situation could have been one of those
rare examples of a rock human mother
actually engaging
in the art of parentage however if that
were true then that would go on to imply
that josephumi was at least part rock
human and therefore so was josuke which
is an awful lot to assume from a picture
of one woman in a bikini who bears a
mild resemblance at best to dress from
his mother
so yeah i think we'll just leave this
thought here for now
it is just very interesting that arki
chose this woman to be the focal point
though but the reference in this chapter
that most obviously sticks out to me
though
is of course the stone mask which is i
think the first time that we've seen one
in the alternate universe outside of
some bonus content in part seven
i mean feel free to let me know if i'm
wrong but i'm pretty sure this is our
first sighting of a stone mask
isn't it and on a physique that looks
suspiciously like a certain
deo like a proper dio as well not a
diego brando
which is just a little bit slightly what
the hell
i mean there's no guarantee that it's
dear but surely it's heavily implied to
be
because i mean who else is it going to
be i mean maybe it's one of the pillar
men
and in fact just hold that thought for a
second because by virtue of the stone
masks existing in the first place
does that mean that there is or i should
say there was alternate universe
versions of the pillarmen and if so that
just makes me so ridiculously keen to
see a flashback of say alternate
universe joseph and whatever the
equivalent of their battle tendency
events were but the raging tsunami of
thoughts bombarding my mind did not stop
there because on that very same page we
saw enya again
which isn't necessarily anything special
on its own because she was in steel ball
run
although i don't know at this point who
knows if that was actually her or just a
character bearing a startling
resemblance
because the key thing about enya in this
chapter is that she is wielding the
stand arrows which should not
exist in this world because we have a
different mechanism by which we gain
stands in part seven and eight
which isn't to say that they definitely
cannot exist i just ask myself
why though because they serve no greater
purpose in the alternate universe much
like the stone mask and this is probably
an insane insane thought but the thing
that came to mind for me was maybe
what we are seeing is not the alternate
universe perhaps what we're seeing is a
brief flashback to the original universe
anarki is implying that rock humans also
existed there as well
retroactively labeling enya dio and even
potentially hermes as
rock humans which is something that i do
really like the idea of
because it would thread part 8 well and
truly in with the core fabric of jojo
but it is
possibly quite a bit of a stretch to
make mostly because of how these panels
play out sequentially you know we see
the steel ball run stuff which we'll
talk about in a second because there's a
lot there as well but then we cut to the
stone mask then enya and then it's
immediately josephumi and kira in
alternate universe mario which i suppose
would imply that this is a chronological
order of events
and the other thing that very much goes
against my idea is the fact that while
dio and enya can safely fit into the
whole rock humans thing
hermes is a bit trickier i mean rock
humans are described as fundamentally
independent and have no families which
is certainly not true in fact family was
the greatest driving factor
of the hermes character and she also
formed a very strong bond with jolene
which we are told should not be possible
for rock humans so as much as it might
have been a fun idea to think about
i do think what we are seeing here is
more than likely strictly alternate
universe stuff which is fascinating in
its own right because it just did evoke
so much
like it's seriously amazing how araki
can show two simple panels of a stone
mask and the thoughts that spawn from
that are just so
vast and sprawling which occurs a lot in
this chapter and it really was a pure
pleasure to read
more of this though my favorite part of
chapter 99 was seeing the steel ball
cast because it is still far and away my
favorite part and just being able to see
the phenomenal duo of johnny and gyro
again
makes this chapter for me everything
else could have been utter undergarbage
and i still would have loved it although
thankfully everything else is also
incredibly solid and meaty
so we have no worries there but it does
appear in the ever intriguing montage
segment
after we're told that rock humans have a
fascination with ground rock and stone
seeing blessings from the earth has true
benefits and then make quote unquote
special places that give rocuments
special power the implication being that
the devil's palm and the ground of mario
would have been said special and or
sacred places both of which we know how
they came to be
via corpse eclopsy power the second of
which was due to johnny but
what is this part with lucy why is she
in mario why does she work with the
speedwagon foundation which is now
a thing in this universe by the way and
why does lucy look so
damn ominous like if i didn't know any
better and
actually i most certainly don't it looks
like lucy is making the decision to
leave the holy cops in mario
for reasons i don't know what those
reasons are but we never actually found
out what happened to the corpse after
johnny's death i mean there were just a
bunch of agents present one of which
very much could have been lucy looking
at it again and that may
quite well explain the ongoing
shenanigans of mario but that does go on
to be weird again because does that
imply that lucy is purposely creating or
cultivating this place of power and may
or may not be a rock human herself i
mean i don't think so because it doesn't
match her personality profile
at all but i suppose that the holy
corpse is either still in moria which
would be very exciting or that the
effect of the corpse is more or less
permanent and that mario is now going to
be this eternally twisted place
so much to think about and yet so little
of the chapter actually reviewed at this
point
should probably move on and in fact one
very important thing to mention is that
the threat of this chapter is toru who
once again has snapped back into the
position of big
bad guy thing i mean the cover page of
the chapter is practically spelling out
the fact that the head doctor is indeed
his stand
and while i still think that's kind of
insane i do have to admit that so are
all of the stands wielded by the primary
antagonist of any given jojo series i
mean i was still kind of hoping that it
would be jobin because toru came out of
nowhere
comparatively that is and i still don't
have the same sort of vibe with him that
i did would say valentine
pucci diavolo or name any other main
antagonist really so it will be
interesting to see if he actually is
defeated right here and now
because it would seem like a bit of a
stretch to reveal him as the grand
central master of anti-human chaos
just to have josuke deal with him
immediately i feel like that would be
pretty unsatisfying but who knows
because we very much do need to deal
with this whole endless calamity
business
before anything else can really happen
that or yasuho is just going to spend
the remainder of the series writhing in
agony on the ground
also possible it could very well be a
steel ball run scenario though where the
main antagonist is taken out and then
the more epilogic section of the story
focuses on jobin much like how diego was
used in part 7.
i can't say i have any particularly
strong thoughts on the confrontation
between josuke the wonder of you which
is the name of the head doctor stand
and mamazuku i feel like we're still
very much in the same place as we left
off before
just with slightly more information and
josuke having a bit more crap on his
face and you know what actually with the
whole toru is the main antagonist thing
coming to fruition i think i said last
chapter that wouldn't it be cool if
josuke dealt with this whole fight while
sitting down
while that has been taken to a whole new
level now so wouldn't it be cool if
josuke defeated the main antagonist of
the series
whilst remaining completely sedentary it
would certainly
be different but an unexpected highlight
of this chapter for me
was seeing a bit of mamazuka's past and
i think this was very necessary because
in the same way that toru is a late
emerging main antagonist mamazuku was
also a bit of a late joe bro in the
grand scheme of things so it's nice to
see he's being expanded upon and
incorporated directly into the whole
head doctor business with the calamity
claiming the life of his father it just
gives him such a great purpose to be
right here right now with josuke facing
off against the wonder of you
and for the first time in the series i
feel somewhat connected to him i mean
i've always liked mamazuki because he's
quirky and supremely analytical but to
say that i've ever felt anything
for him before now it would definitely
be a lie
but that has very much changed as a
result of this chapter and i am much
more invested in his general existence
and furthermore i look forward to seeing
how he and josuke end up overcoming the
popsicle sticks of doom
but yeah look i know there's probably a
lot about chapter 99 that i
didn't even touch on but all in all it
was a fantastic experience that took us
on a journey through the history of jojo
in a really compelling way and at this
point
i simply cannot wait to see what chapter
100 has in store for us but what do you
guys think
please do let me know down in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
jojo content then please do go and check
out some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
jojo wonder delivered straight to your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review
and i'll see you next time